boxing has massively helped my mental
health without I don't know where I'd be
what happens with most boys what
happened to me is 16 17. got him with
the wrong crowd started drinking started
doing this and that and so I lost my way
I guess she did some of the issues with
Sam's being and I see myself in him
struggling really for somewhere to go
somewhere to see and probably somebody
feel accepted
the people in Europe like a family that
I've never met before like you're really
close to them like no matter what they
can talk to you even if you're feeling
down and they've always got your back
[Music]
boxing is massively disciplined me keeps
me forecast it keeps me fit it keeps me
healthy body and mind and now I'm going
on to finish my degree and be a
qualified teacher